and what about men where are you at with
this you're only 22 but are you finding
love did you find love in college and
can you date you have not I have not
found love no would you would you go
public with that on your feed like let's
say you find a boy and you have to have
boyfriends right you've had boyfriends
oh yeah I have
um do you put them on you don't you
don't put them on their feet or you do I
I did and then you know that was a
little crazy breaking up like a public
breakup because
a little crazy out there and everyone
has their opinions and then it's like
not only are you going through a breakup
but then it's like I'm scrolling through
and I'm seeing everyone else post about
my breakup and I'm like well this
is making it worse like yeah yeah but I
don't know I'm just dating around right
now and having fun and nothing serious I
don't want anything serious right now
and these guys you got to be really
careful who you go out with right I
guess I don't know there's a lot of a
lot of out there yeah yeah do
you have a good detector or
have you been I think I do but I won't
what happened I don't know I'm and then
I'm just thinking about like oh past
things I'm like maybe I don't anyone
famous ever slide into your DMs uh we've
had a few really how old are these guys
who are sliding into your deal are they
around your age or a little bit older
we've got a mix of both so some are
older no kidding how old is old uh 40s
40s yeah you're a 22 year old child I
know I know you wouldn't date a guy in
his 40s would you
depends who it is I'm a personality
person I mean I'm one of those
I'm pretty clear on that you got a
really low personality to go out with me
thank you